it's a busy week for Fulton County
Superior Judge Scott McAfee while
hearing an ongoing murder trial he's
also dealing with procedural issues in
the wide-ranging election racketeering
case he's received a brief from the
prosecution arguing why all 19
defendants should be tried together and
we'll hear further argument on the
matter in court on Thursday
judge McAfee has already ruled that the
trial of two of the defendants should
begin on October the 23rd Trump aligned
lawyers Kenneth chesbro and Sydney
Powell have been granted a speedy trial
under Georgia law demands for a speedy
trial must be met within two months of
entering a plea or the charges are
dropped it's now up to the judge to
decide whether the trial on 23rd of
October will involve all 19 defendants
or just the two who've asked for a
speedy trial that could lead to all the
defendants being separated into groups
Donald Trump's lawyers have already
given notice that the former president
wishes to be tried alone
the judge will also hear prosecution
requests that the identities of jurors
in the case be kept secret this comes in
the wake of online attacks on members of
the special grand jury which met last
year and who were identified in
accordance with Georgia tradition
this resulted in an unprecedented
decision to withhold the identities of
those who were part of a subsequent
grand jury that actually recommended the
indictment of the 19 defendants
a protection the prosecution once
afforded to those selected to hear the
trial itself
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Atlanta
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera